now what should I recall the very first
lesson we did right I showed you this we
drew up and said axes you don't need to
call this okay
and then I said we talked about I think
we talked about mandarins who said man
yeah okay I know we said like two
dollars a kilo and then we plotted some
points and then we drew this and
something like that now what we drew is
what we drew was this if you call this Y
and this X which is what they usually
are okay
what we did was we took a rule we took
this equation right and then we plot
some points we've joined together and
that was the line that we caused right
that was the graph so in other words we
went from a rule to a graph a rule to
breath okay today we're gonna go in the
opposite direction right we're going to
find the rule of graph we're gonna have
a graph and then go to the rule okay so
I'm going in the reverse direction all
right so you got page 245 then and I I
need two gestures water you don't have
to draw it because you've got it in
front of you but I'm gonna draw the
graph for 1a okay so you can class your
eyes onto that now that's great you
don't need to as I'm saying okay now Shh
let's replace a little bit let's revise
of it last time I wasn't here but you
covered two important features about a
graph right two important features why
not to do with like how how slope is
house what slant it had and the other
was about where it hit one of the axes
do you remember what they were
what were the chippies information
gradients good so thank you so great it
was about the slope okay in fact
gradient another word for it is
okay now we'll talk about how to work it
out in a second we will get there the
other thing was the y-intercept now on
this diagram where is the y-intercept
it's where in this case it's where the
blue line right it meets the y-axis
which is the vertical right so in other
words it's actually there right there
okay in this case yes it's positive
because it's above zero above zero okay
good so what we got to do is we want to
work out what the y-intercept is what
the gradient is and then we can write
down the rule of the equation of the
graph
okay so first we'll do the way to set
because it's really easy it's quite
simple you've actually got a scale on
yours can you tell me what is that value
hold on it's with that it's with the
medical it's one there's a minus one
here that's okay that's a useful thing
as well but it's not the y-intercept
it's the what would you call it see how
this is the intercept like it's win
again of the y-axis so it's the
y-intercept well that minus one is uh
where it meets the x-axis right so what
would you call that then you call it the
x-intercepts right so I might I might
actually just put that in so let me just
repeat that you told me the y-intercept
okay where it hits the y-axis but down
here you've got the x-intercept which is
where it hits the x-axis okay right so
like you said the way the sift is just
equal to 1
okay now by the way you learned that
there was a particular matter that
usually gets associated with it was it
was be very good yeah so I'm gonna say B
equals 1 right now I want to find the
gradient the gradient a bit trickier but
it's still all that hard to find um what
was the letter then we associated with
the gradient very good so we're gonna
get M equals something okay now how do I
work it out off of here there's two
different ways okay you want to suggest
what ya the gradient how'd I work it out
cool it so grating at em right equals
rise over now this is a really important
idea I'm gonna show you two ways to work
it out okay on one way which is a bit
quicker but doesn't work all the time
and then a way which is a bit longer but
no matter what gradually get it'll
always work okay so here's the easy way
to do it so maybe we can say you know
easy method okay the easy method is you
want a triangle on here which has rise
and run on it you can draw a whole bunch
of different ones okay but for me it
looks like and actually this is where it
will be useful to have a diagram of some
kind right
I can see triangle in here look at this
one can you see that triangle yes and
the important thing about it is its
right-angled okay so you've got this
part the vertical part which is the rise
okay and then you've got this horizontal
part which is the run right how funds go
up how far to go across okay that in
this case well you've got you've got um
the axis the y-axis give you numbers
right so we're gonna use those numbers
right since you told me the y-intercept
is 1 that means the rise is 1 so that's
gone up 1 in that train were there okay
how far has it gone to the right how far
hasn't run now be careful be careful
this this number the x intercept is
minus 1 but I'm going I'm going this way
went to the right okay so that is just 1
okay the rise in this case is 1 and the
run is also 1 okay yep yeah okay I'm
always thinking about going going
forward in time if you like okay so I'm
always going this way always now let's
just quickly I lose rise is one right is
1 so rise over run is 1 over 1 which is
just just 1 right
ok now he's
thing right you never I said we draw
triangle that's the easy method draw a
triangle you can actually draw a whole
bunch of different triangles for
instance I'm gonna draw a bigger one
okay I'm gonna draw it like this and you
can see where it is on your diagram okay
now here's the important thing about
this right if it's a straight line you
can draw the triangle wherever you want
and however big or small you want and
you still get the same result now let's
suppose if you look at your graph you
look up your graph and you get something
like I'm just gonna pick one of them if
this is 4 then this would be fun okay
have a look at that for me
now I still work out the same things
rise and run okay let's look at this
part the run is easier I'm going your
diagram goes like all the way up to 5
actually so have a look can you see the
axes this is 2 1 X 2 1 I'm still in the
same one so you can see I go through 0
to 4 so what's the run it's just 4
excellent okay what's the lies now it's
4 again yeah very good
it starts at 1 and then it goes up to 5
and the difference
that's the rise the difference is 4 ok
now you can see if I did rise over run
again either before or before which is
still 1 same line same gradient ok sir
hey happy with that does that make sense
ok now before I get to the trickier
method let me just show you what you do
with these just got em and you've got B
right we're gonna put them together to
make the rule okay
okay so no no what are we how are we
gonna put these together do you remember
this a pretty different color remember
look at this y equals MX plus B do you
have that did you see it yeah yeah no no
okay all right well let me show it to
you now this is where the two numbers go
right you've worked out em and you
worked out B okay the rule of the
equation of our line is going to look
like this all you have to do is take
your two numbers and put him in okay so
for instance M is equal to 1 so this
would just be how many X's 1 and B will
be 1 done skis that's it ok so that is
where that's that's the rule that gives
you this line and you can check any
other value on there right find an x
value
stick it in right for instance put in x
equals negative 1 and that puts you over
here y is equal to negative 1 plus on
which is zero okay so there you go
that's the answer okay